bienvenidos he hecho una serie de
presentaciones acerca de vivienda y mi
teoría del por qué han aumentado los
precios de estas y cómo pueden ver en
términos generales la comparación entre
comprar o rentar pero muchas personas me
dicen que estoy simplificando demasiado
de las cosas y suponiendo intereses
solamente del préstamo nuestro
incluyendo las deducciones de impuestos
sobre hipotecas etcétera y así es
simplifica muchas cosas para poder hacer
cálculos sencillos y poder comprender
mejor los conceptos de comprar contra
renta pero es cierto que la realidad hay
muchas cosas que considerar al momento
de decidir entre comprar o rentar un
inmueble así que necesitamos un modelo
multi línea en donde podamos descubrir
lo que podría pasar en cada caso y
también jugar y ajustar nuestras
suposiciones para ver qué podría pasar
si se aprecia la vivienda o se deprecia
o si cambian las tasas de interés o si
damos 10 por ciento o 20 por ciento de
adelanto etcétera
en nuestra mente construye este modelo
que llamo modelo de compra de vivienda
el cual ustedes pueden descargar y jugar
con él para que les sea útil pueden
descargarlo del sitio de khan academy
khan academy punto o hereje diagonal
download diagonal by brent punto x ls es
una hoja de cálculo de excel incluso
podrían descargarla abrirla en excel y
seguirme en este vídeo ahora permítanme
explicar mis suposiciones en este modelo
lo que está resaltado en amarillo
incluyendo a este amarillo brillante
solo estas suposiciones son las cosas
que van a guiar a conducir nuestro
modelo y hacer cálculos para los
próximos 10 años para saber si nos
convendría más rentar en lugar de
comprar o viceversa si descargan este
modelo para jugar con él ustedes mismos
a menos de que sean muy sofisticados en
el uso de excel las únicas cosas que
deberían cambiar son los datos
resaltados en amarillo todos
además está calculado a partir de estos
datos qué es lo que nos interesa al
comprar una casa pues el precio de
compra el avance de pago o el adelanto
de pago el cual pueden ponerlo como
porcentaje del precio de venta o la
cantidad tal cual aquí está la tasa de
interés que suponemos aquí está la
amortización principal significa que si
yo sigo pagando esta hipoteca después de
cuánto tiempo se habrá terminado de
pagar el capital principal y no sólo el
interés en esencia tenemos un préstamo
de pago fijo a 30 años con una
amortización a 30 años si tuviéramos un
préstamo a 10 años aquí pondríamos un 10
esta es la tasa de impuestos a la
propiedad y esto es lo que yo supongo
con base en el impuesto de la ciudad de
donde vivo este es mi supuesto de
mantenimiento anual podría ser mayor o
menor dependiendo de la propiedad
estos son los pagos o cuotas asociadas
con la vivienda por ejemplo si viven en
una comunidad donde todos comparten un
campo de golf o una piscina
ignacio o algo similar estas serían las
cuotas si no pongan esto en ceros esto
es el seguro anual contra imprevistos
incendios terremotos inundaciones o
cualquier seguro que necesiten tener en
donde viven y aquí resaltado en amarillo
brillante está en su puesto de
apreciación anual de la vivienda esta es
una suposición enorme y es por eso que
la resalte más pues veremos más adelante
en el vídeo que esta suposición es hasta
cierto punto uno de los conductores o
guías principales en este modelo el cual
es mucho muy sensible a esta suposición
esta es nuestra tasa de impuesto al
ingreso marginal que suponemos porque
nos interesa esto pues porque se puede
deducir el interés de lo que pagamos de
hipoteca y también podemos deducir el
impuesto a la propiedad así que si
podemos deducir 100 dólares de los
intereses de impuesto a la vivienda si
nuestra tasa de impuesto marginal es del
30% significa la tasa de impuesto por
cada dólar incremental es
de 100 dólares de intereses podremos
deducir 30 dólares si la tasa de
impuesto de ingreso marginal es 20 por
ciento una deducción de 100 dólares nos
ahorrará 20 dólares este 2% representa
la inflación general esto indica que
siempre habrá algo de inflación sobre
cosas como las cuotas asociadas con la
vivienda mantenimiento anual seguros
etcétera por lo que esto nos indica la
tasa general de inflación y en el modelo
esto va a indicar que tanto crecerán
éstos anualmente durante la vida del
préstamo y una vez que ingresamos estas
cantidades se calculará el pago mensual
de la hipoteca aquí suponemos que el
interés es compuesto mensualmente y si
ustedes conocen sus series geométricas
pueden modificar y jugar con esto por
unos intereses que se componen con mayor
o menor frecuencia pero tengo entendido
que la mayoría de los préstamos tienen
intereses compuestos mensuales todo esto
que acabamos de ver es lo necesario para
calcular los elementos para comprar una
casa
estas cosas de aquí abajo son las que
corresponden a rentar una casa y así
podremos comparar ambas situaciones por
ejemplo qué pasaría si usáramos el pago
de adelanto para la compra de la casa y
lo ahorraremos en el banco y rentamos la
casa en su lugar así que este es el
costo de rentar una casa similar
esta es la suposición de la inflación en
la renta yo soy de la opinión de que la
inflación en la renta de una vivienda no
es tan diferente de la apreciación anual
de una vivienda a largo plazo ya que la
renta es digamos que la ganancia de una
vivienda y si las ganancias aumentan
pero no aumentan los bienes en general
el rendimiento aumentará o viceversa
pero no quiero confundirlos con estos
detalles este 6% que yo supongo aquí es
el rendimiento que obtengo del efectivo
si yo no doy estos 150 mil de adelanto
de la compra de la vivienda y lo
invierto no sé en el mercado de valores
quizás pueda recibir un 20% al año o
quizá no me gusta arriesgarme y lo
invierto en bonos del gobierno
y obtengo un 4% anual esta es la
suposición que hacemos al respecto y de
hecho debe ser un rendimiento después
del pago de impuestos así que si mi tasa
de impuestos es del 30% y yo creo que
puedo obtener un 10% en el mercado de
valores por ejemplo aquí debo poner un
7% queremos asegurarnos de ser muy
precisos aquí considerando los impuestos
ahora les voy a explicar el resto del
modelo todas las suposiciones que
hicimos aquí nos van a ayudar a calcular
todo esto de acá está el escenario de
compra en el periodo cero tendremos este
valor de vivienda a quien lo hay que
cambiar o modificar nada todo se calcula
automáticamente aquí tenemos el valor de
la vivienda que se va apreciando cada
mes mostrando el valor de mercado de la
vivienda que es calculado usando el
valor de apreciación esto de aquí abajo
es la deuda o el pago principal de la
hipoteca o qué tanto se le debe al banco
y como pueden ver con el paso del tiempo
cada que se paga la hipoteca
de este pago va a pagar el capital para
decrementar la deuda aunque la mayor
parte de este pago va a pagar los
intereses sobre todo al inicio y aquí
tenemos el equilibrio en la vivienda que
es el valor de la vivienda menos la
deuda que se le debe al banco está
cantidad nos dice el valor de la
inversión en cierto momento del tiempo
todo esto se calcula con los datos que
ingresamos al inicio y todos estos son
los cálculos importantes en el escenario
de compra el interés en la deuda se
calcula con la tasa de interés
multiplicada por la deuda que se tiene
del período anterior el pago de la
hipoteca que calculamos antes usando
nuestro conocimiento matemático de
series geométricas el pago del capital
principal que se da del pago de la
hipoteca menos el interés el pago del
seguro que es mensual tomamos nuestro
pago de seguro anual y lo dividimos
entre 12 y luego lo crecemos con la tasa
de inflación mensual lo mismo sucede con
las cuotas asociadas a la vivienda pero
calculadas mensualmente eso lo dividimos
entre 12 meses
para el mantenimiento del impuesto a la
vivienda es lo mismo aunque yo supongo
que su vivienda es revaluada quizás se
encuentren en un estado en el que cada
año o cada cierta cantidad de años llega
un asesor a decir el valor actual de esa
vivienda y cuál es el ajuste respectivo
de los impuestos este ahorro en el
impuesto de ingresos de la deducción de
intereses suponiendo que a esa tasa de
impuesto marginal se le puede deducir el
impuesto de la propiedad y el interés de
la deuda
este es el flujo de efectivo que pudo
usarse en gastos o compras de la casa
esta es la cantidad de efectivo que sale
por la puerta aún después del ahorro de
impuestos cada mes en el escenario de
compra y espero que todo esto tenga
sentido lo que queremos hacer es
comparar lo que sucede en el escenario
de compra de la vivienda dar un adelanto
de 150 mil dólares y cada mes pagar esta
cantidad que podemos ver que este número
aumenta aunque la hipoteca sea la misma
pues estos otros gastos crecen con la
inflación por el escenario de renta
tomando esta misma cantidad de dinero
después de ajustar la cantidad de dinero
que recibo con los impuestos que debo
pagar y decir que voy a usar ese
efectivo para pagar mi renta y los otros
gastos asociados con rentar una casa los
cuales no son muchos es decir pago mi
renta y pongo todo lo demás en el banco
si nuestras oposiciones que rentamos una
casa similar por 2500 dólares no sé si
sea correcto esto o no a ustedes les
toca jugar con esto esto va a ir
creciendo poco a poco con la inflación
aunque la renta no aumenta mes con mes
aquí lo suponemos así ya que es un
aumento gradual aunque si ustedes
quieren pueden modificar esto para que
aumente cada año
esta línea de aquí abajo nos indica los
ahorros cuando rentamos y son ahorros
con respecto a lo que tenemos guardado
en el banco a rentar en lugar de dar los
150 mil dólares como adelanto podrían
guardarlo en el banco en su cuenta de
ahorros en el periodo cero y durante el
periodo 1 tendremos esto más su
rendimiento más la diferencia entre el
gasto de efectivo de la compra de la
vivienda y la renta así que estos son
los ahorros lo que hice en este modelo
es hacer los cálculos de varios periodos
aquí se los muestro y cualquiera que
esté familiarizado con la compra de
vivienda les dirá que el préstamo
promedio de hipotecas tiene una vida
esperada de 10 años y es cuando las
personas en promedio buscan mudarse y
refinanciar su préstamo
a las suposiciones de entrada cualquiera
que ésta sea cuál será el valor de la
vivienda después de diez años la deuda
después de diez años el equilibrio de la
vivienda después de diez años y
suponemos que quieren vender la vivienda
qué es lo que hace la mayoría de los
estadounidenses después de diez años
aquí está el costo asociado a la
transacción de la venta de la vivienda
por ejemplo el 10% que recibe el agente
inmobiliario y la línea 54 nos dice cuál
será el efectivo neto al vender la casa
en el precio de mercado y pagándole al
agente inmobiliario el número de aquí
abajo es más sencillo porque nos dice
que si decidimos no vender la casa y
tomando todas nuestras suposiciones
cuánto habremos ahorrado en el banco
hasta ese momento
este número de acá es la diferencia
entre estos dos números en 10 años
descontados hasta el día de hoy es decir
el valor presente el valor presente
sería si descontamos esto por una tasa
de descuento que se considere
probablemente la tasa de inflación
y le dirá que es el dinero actual cuál
será el beneficio o ventaja de comprar
contra rentar los invito a que
descarguen este modelo jueguen con él y
consideren bien las suposiciones pues
esto es lo más importante de todo el
modelo de ellas depende el que deciden
si les conviene rentar o les conviene
comprar quizás se hagan suposiciones que
padezcan muy razonables como este 3 por
ciento de precisión anual de la vivienda
pero es sorprendente cuánto cambiaría el
modelo si pasáramos este 3% a un 1 por
ciento o incluso a un menos 1 o menos 2
por ciento lo cual es completamente
posible y ya ha sucedido con
anterioridad donde se ha depreciado la
vivienda durante largos periodos de
tiempo incluso a diez años varios
estudios han encontrado que los bienes
inmobiliarios apenas han crecido un 1
por ciento durante los últimos 100 años
de hecho un 1 por ciento aquí sería
bastante conservador especialmente
después de la explosión inmobiliaria
esto sería algo bastante prudente
y que jueguen con sus suposiciones lo
que les dará una intuición sobre cuáles
son los conductores reales aquí otra
cosa es que a veces no se renta una casa
similar sino una más pequeña lo que nos
dará otro tipo de ahorros y otras cosas
por el estilo de cualquier manera espero
que les sea útil este modelo ya que esta
es una de las inversiones más
importantes en la vida y merece un
análisis serio yo creo que este modelo
puede ser de gran ayuda al respecto
disfrútelo y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo